when not if but when the NFL season
begins in September Russell Wilson will
continue to be playing for the Seattle
Seahawks but Chris and what a slow fuse
this was it's been 11 days now since we
did a PFT ot segment on untouchable
players untradable players and this was
all sparked by the suggestion the
bengals under no circumstances would
have traded the number one overall pick
this year making joe burrow without ever
playing a game in the NFL untradable
which is kind of ludicrous because he's
unproven so we tried to list the guys
who really can't be traded and we agreed
Patrick mahomes can't be traded wouldn't
be traded Lamar Jackson can't be traded
wouldn't be traded Aaron Rodgers can't
be traded because of his cap hit and
maybe wouldn't be traded although who
the hell knows at this point and then we
came to Russell Wilson fairly innocuous
comment that you made and it wasn't the
first time you mentioned it there was
some chatter about the Seahawks talking
to the Browns about the number one
overall pick and the 2018 draft and you
said it we talked about it we went about
our business and nobody said anything
for like a week it like just sat there
and then eventually people noticed it
eventually people reacted to it and for
me what happened was people who are
relevant to the conversations relevant
to the circumstances they started
getting texted by reporters asking them
questions so I had like questions to me
like what the hell did you guys do what
did you say and that's how it all blew
up on Thursday it's it's crazy because
we know like you said I didn't really
realize it blew up either I had some
people texting me last Wednesday night
hey we know we'd love to have you out
and talk about Russell Russell Wilson
stuff and I remember going on pro
football talk like the news break about
Russell Wilson's and I'm not we're aware
of and you know to what you said also
Mike I don't know when I brought this up
the first time around which I want to
say was some some time early in the 2019
season maybe training camp right around
that that time but hey listen long story
short
you know the 2018 draft and Baker
Mayfield Josh Allen and that whole group
of guys yes I was told you know not long
after the 2018 draft by somebody
connected to one of the teams that that
was a conversation that was had I didn't
was never told that it got deep into
conversations there was never a point of
oh hey let me go back to my people and
let's talk about what you know what we
need to do to make this work I was just
told that that was floated out there for
the Cleveland Browns and that yes you
know I think there was you know some
gauging of the temperature there where
that might go and then I just sat there
didn't really know anything about it
right and oh man that's an interesting
you know a little tidbit and then a few
months with that went by and I talked to
somebody else that bob was one of these
two teams and they kind of confirmed it
to me and that's where you know I
finally had the guts finally to say it
on TV or our podcast I can't remember
where I send initially but you know
that's really the gist of the story and
you know the people I've got telling me
this or a pretty high level and in the
know so I was never led to like believe
that this is a rumor or bullcrap or
something that was out there I was being
told by people that were in the direct
know of the situation and again I don't
know how far it got but I do know John
Dorsey and John Schneider have a very
good relationship and I think there was
a conversation between those two men at
one point or it's funny because we'll
get accused of trying to sensational
eyes and to get to conjure up clickbait
and look if that was the case I'd have
written the story the day that you
mentioned it the first time at a minimum
I had done it last Thursday not four
days ago eleven days ago when you
blurted it out again during PFT ot but I
mean I it's it it for whatever reason I
didn't lock on to it and say hey I got
to go make this the top story at PFT but
last Thursday four days ago
when I start getting contacted by people
who would know what happened who do know
what happened who are curious about why
all of a sudden this is at their
doorstep right
the normal conversation start saying
things to me that make it damn clear
that it happened that was time to
mobilize that was time to write about it
and that was time to try to push a
little bit forward as to what may happen
into the future Chris and look there are
people who think that Russell Wilson
eventually is going to get traded not
that it definitely will happen but that
this sense this this dynamic between
Wilson and the Seahawks is very quiet
and contained I don't want to say
acrimony but there's tension there's
tension they've been through multiple
difficult negotiations and Wilson has
won both of them significantly and one
of the reasons why he wins these
negotiations he's got an agent who
represents one football client he's like
Tom Hagen from the Godfather he's got
one client he doesn't have to worry
about five other players who play for
the Seahawks and properly having the
right relationship so those guys don't
get screwed if the Seahawks are mad at
him because of the bargain that he drove
for to get for Russell Wilson when you
have one client in the entire NFL you
can take a much different approach to
how you represent that client because
you don't have that broader relationship
you have to worry about and Russell
Wilson has done a great job of getting
great contracts 35 million per year on
only a four-year extension we talk about
what Zach Prescott's trying to get from
the Cowboys
if dak Prescott was represented only by
an agent who had one and only one client
in the NFL maybe it would be easier for
him to get what he wants but that's
that's what's been beneficial to Russell
Wilson but it's all Kirk also created
this vague sense Chris that that
something could happen and the reason
there's a no trade clause in the current
contract for Russell Wilson the the
reason for that no trade clause right is
what you've mentioned multiple times
that after that time to talk it's about
trading Russell Wilson right right you
know and again I you know I we're not
really hearing anybody within either
organization come out and go no this is
totally no he said no no nobody said
something to connect all right right
right nothing in the Cleveland Plain
Dealer
so
no fake news nothing in the Seattle
Times or any of the Seattle papers
saying fake news where's John Doerr sees
John Dorsey come out and said this is
love this is ludicrous i Vince's I
there's never been a conversation like
that in my life John Schneider nothing
and here's the thing we got to remember
their former colleagues in Green Bay
right they know each other well and it
don't have to be a who called whom first
right it's as simple as these guys talk
on a regular basis they're friends
they're just spitballing like you and
I'm talking about something the topic
comes up and maybe the topic comes up
it's like oh this is intriguing why I'd
never thought about that you are you
suggesting that you would be willing to
trade russell wilson whoa in the in
theory we've got the first pick in the
fourth pick what would anything i mean
if you're a is this something that you
actually would do and they talk about a
little bit and then they realize it's
not gonna work but doesn't mean they
didn't talk about it it doesn't mean
topic for conversation and and it's just
it's a man and in this I'm so used to
this now the Seahawks fans who don't
want to hear it are just gonna plug
their ears and shout and say that anyone
who is suggesting any set of facts
different from their worldview it's just
lying well okay fine think what you want
to thank but under these circumstances
something happened something was
discussed and to me the big takeaway is
it's something that can come around
again and just because there's a no
trade clause doesn't mean he can't be
traded all it means as Russell Wilson
controls his destination yeah that's
right and you know that's the bottom
line
something was discussed you know again I
didn't throw this out there to be like
let me see if I can cause a stir and get
a few headlines and some clickbait you
know no I'm not into that I mean you
know I know people thought I thought
that or thought that when I said New
England it was gonna be I mean with
Brady was gonna be New England and Tampa
Bay why I'm not into the news-breaking
business you know I know a lot of people
around football and you know I get
information all the time this is one
that was said to me by somebody in the
very much in the know where I just sat
there one who that's interesting and
then like I said got it confirmed more
and more to where I went all right I
think
few people that know about this now I'm
gonna board it out one of these days on
the show and that's how I went like like
you said you I don't think this
discussions got real serious but I think
the discussions happen I mean I know
they happen so that's all there is to
that and you know also to with the
relationship with Russell Wilson in that
discussion
you know you have Russell Wilson it's
been a very weird relationship with an
organization that he's the face of and
has been to two Super Bowls but you know
a lot of that was hey one the team kind
of hated on him for years the defensive
players I feel like didn't want to
really give Russell Wilson the respect
maybe he deserved or maybe they felt
like they were being slighted I don't
know either way I think that hurt
Russell Wilson's in the eyes of the
locker room and the team that way and
you know you're right with their agent
and his him having only Russell Wilson
is his only guy there it allows him to
you know put teams and put a teamspeak
over the fire a little bit more than
maybe you would if you had a lot of
clients and let's not forget the biggest
point the Seattle Seahawks went to two
Super Bowls because John Schneider and
Pete Carroll drafted a quarterback and
Russell Wilson in the middle of the
draft got him on a rookie contract and
built an unbelievable team around him
and a great defense and I think those
are two guys I think they can do that
again and you know I think they have
that self-confidence so they were
probably dabbling in that ideal a little
bit around the 2018 and I fell dropped
man we're gonna have to play Russell
wasn't a lot of money man maybe we
should just try to do what we did the
first time around and see if we can get
rid of this money get a young
quarterback build a defense in a roster
again and see if we can't play that same
way and be successful and I think that's
that's really the gist of it they're
experimenting you could say with the
concept of having Russell Wilson at the
top of the pay scale for a few years to
see what kind of a team they can put
around him when he's got 35 million per
year coming to him and because it's a
short-term extension relative to these
six-year deals we see Aaron Rodgers like
signed six years into the future he did
that twice now
Russell Wilson has twice signed a
four-year extension he will be back at
the trough again and the Seahawks and
Wilson will be back in that posture
again and then
next time around is the time that he
could be traded next time could be the
time that what he wants is so much more
than what the Seahawks want to pay that
they decide set the clock back to 2012
where they say we're gonna get a guy
who's coming out of college and you
think of how different it is now in 2012
it really was a crapshoot with college
quarterbacks now we see they're hitting
far more often than they aren't and if
you had a quarterback you go to round
one you do your scouting and you bring a
guy in and you let him do at the college
level and the NFL level the same thing
don't try to turn him into something
that he isn't already and that has
resulted in success for plenty of teams
so look and back to your point on how
the teammates treated him this is basic
playground mentality he was viewed as a
goody-two-shoes he was viewed by company
man they resented Russell Wilson they
were jealous of Russell Wilson they
mocked Russell Wilson and the go Hawks
mantra and what what happened over time
they peeled out of the organization the
guys who resented Russell Wilson and
they've built it around him but just
because it's built around him for now
doesn't mean it's permanent and they can
go back to the way it was when this next
contract gets to a point where the
salary cap hit won't be devastating in
that window opens in 2022 Chris yeah you
know again I think a lot of me on the
state of the Seattle Seahawks
organization in general you know where's
where's Pete Carroll at in his career
how much longer does he want to go how
much longer does John Schneider want to
go what's the quality of the roster of
the football team you know I think you
know again I think you're right in a lot
of ways where if we get here from two
years from now and the teams in a pretty
good spot where they feel like okay we
built up the roster again we got some
young talent we got depth behind it and
all that do they really want to pay
Russell Wilson 47 million dollars a year
as he goes into his late 40s I'm not so
sure if Jon cheddar and Pete Carroll
there I would say no you know I don't
think it's gonna happen this contract
negotiation we just went through by
where Russell about four years
you know 135 million well that that was
different you know the team was not
the state of where it could survive by
itself and they realized Russell Wilson
was the greatest asset on their football
team but we see it they're turning this
football team around now and you're
right I mean I just don't think that's
the type of group that's going to put
all their eggs into the the older to
mid-30s Russell Wilson basket when that
time comes and pay him a huge allotment
of money again and yeah I think with
people saying that they think Russell
Wilson can end his career somewhere else
I think that's a very real possibility
as well and he is still just 31 it's
amazing how much more football he has in
front of him and he does multiple times
including on this program he intends to
play until he's 45 I think at one point
you said late 40s paying in big money
late forties that would be impossible
what's a decade among friends for those
of you who read Pro Football Talk calm
and are familiar with the comments that
emerged Thursday night into Friday on
CBS sports radio from former Browns
coach Hugh jacks and now I've said that
John Schneider hasn't said boo about
these conversations regarding a possible
Russell Wilson trade to Cleveland two
years ago John Dorsey the former Browns
GM hasn't said anything either Hugh
Jackson the former Browns coach said to
CBS Sports Radio I'm sure John Dorsey
and John Schneider are really tight I'm
sure if they're having conversations on
their own just jiving around and doing
those kinds of things I would think if
something was serious about that we the
executive team in the organization would
have known I never heard that well look
here's the thing
uh there were many reasons I believe for
John Dorsey to keep this to himself one
of which is Hugh Jackson has a pipeline
to multiple members of the media and he
would have blabbed about it I mean you
can't say anything to Hugh Jackson about
this until you are serious about it and
even then you better make sure Hugh
Jackson signs some sort of an oath right
you got to make sure that this doesn't
get out and I think the best way to
ensure it doesn't get out is to not say
anything to anyone about it I threaten
you Jackson while it's still in the
discussion the conceptual phase and the
other thing you got to worry about his
owner Jimmy Haslam he gets all juiced up
about this and the next thing you know
he takes the bull by the horns and he
makes it happen before you're sure you
want it to happen because look from
Dorsey's perspective I mean you could
say oh it's obvious
you want Russell Wilson over the first
pick in the draft well how do you know
that because you get the first pick in
the draft at a much lower rate than
right Wilson
you'd have been buying Russell Wilson
one year away from making him the
highest-paid player in all of football
right there's a cost-benefit analysis
there that that John Dorsey would want
to engage in thinking maybe Baker
Mayfield at a much lower salary is gonna
be as good as Russell Wilson I mean the
at the time that you haven't made the
pick the potential of that guy you want
to pick exactly Christon 2018 it was
good based on 2019 it wasn't good but
you don't know before you make the pick
what that guy's gonna be no you don't
know and you know again John John Dorsey
and John Schneider pretty good friends
at that you know John Dorsey said
they're about to run a football team
going wait John Schneider I just saw you
win a Super Bowl and go to another Super
Bowl with the rookie quarterback and
build the team around them so no I don't
want Russell Wilson have to pay him
thirty-five million dollars a year I'd
like to do what you've been talking
about in the last few years the Stars
building that Seattle team and how you
did it so you know makes it makes a lot
of sense from that that aspect and again
I don't think this got into the serious
action um they started talking about
assets and what needed to be traded
again this from what I know and I'm
pretty sure I'm a hundred percent right
about this is that it was discussed and
I don't know how much farther went from
there but there was definitely discussed
at some point I figure out how this
comes up over the course of time to the
extent that John Schneider is dealing
with an agent who has one client the Tom
Hagen of football his name is Mark
Rodgers he's a baseball agent he's got
one client he can drive that hard
bargain all the time with the Seahawks
it's gonna frustrate John Schneider so
what's he gonna do he's gonna complain
about it to his friends who's one of his
friends John Dorsey
I mean this could very well have been
the latest chapter as of early 2018 in a
continuation of an ongoing piss and moan
session for lack of a better term sorry
I'm inspired by the spirit of Chris Sims
today we're yeah eventually
Snyder's just complained about it so
much where dorsey's like my mom how
about I take them off your hands I mean
that's how easily it can happen right
that's how he's might happen
Snyder's dreading what's going to come
in 2019 oh I got a deal with this mark
Rogers butthole again and and he's gonna
want it he's gonna want to make this guy
the highest-paid player in football he's
gonna want another four-year extension
hello I really dread this and you never
know what way you know it's it just
happens it just pops out of thin air
when you're having conversations like
that and I think it's very normal
natural for those kinds of conversations
that happen among friends who happen
around pro football teams yeah I mean I
I do too and especially with you know
one GM that like we said here who built
the team you know a certain way the
first time around and when oh wait maybe
do I have a glimmer I could call up my
old buddy here and maybe get a
quarterback at the Sheep rise and see if
I could do it all over again so you know
I again I think the Seattle Seahawks are
one of those teams that think about all
angles have a lot of different plans
they're very well-thought-out and a
detailed organization and John Schneider
and Pete Carroll have shown they're two
of the best that there is in the
business as far as evaluating Talent
having a plan for the direction in which
they want their football team to go and
that's why they basically been to the
playoffs in the last decade because of
the you know those tubes ability to
build a team and and see the future a
little bit and see what they want to do
with the football team yeah something
big cat said on Friday when we reacted
to this and he's absolutely right
Seahawks fans should be very happy about
this not upset because it shows that
they are constantly thinking and
strategizing and trying to come up with
ways to make the team better and if that
includes entertaining the possibility of
trading the most popular player on the
roster so be it if it makes the team
better at least go through the mental
gymnastics and see what's out there all
right we are way way over right out of
the gates but that's okay we'll make it
up on the back end we wanted to have a
full and fair and complete conversation
about the turd we accidentally dropped
into the punchbowl eleven days ago it
was there until four days ago sorry
again
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports